bringing tea Schneider love of metals
first they are do you think D knows how
much you like Sean Paul Jim I probably
does he stop being Sean Paul guy I like
Sean Paul who shot you've heard him
before you feel like playing right now
it's kind of like reggae I'm a
button-pusher you are yeah this would
list less like one one note yeah yeah so
you do you skip through hit it well you
can't I'm so old I'm referring to
pushing the plan it's a little different
now but yeah I skip what would you keep
on why don't you listen to if it came on
every time every time yeah yeah a CDC
yeah good job with them to geez here
here I was great it was great it was
like and he was like so not Axl not
right not on stage but like the word was
he showed up on time yeah he was like yo
never late and they asked him about he
said I I can't be late for Angus Young
you can't [ __ ] with a that's amazing I
gotta be shorter you know yeah Jim just
wants to be taller than everybody in the
room he's got that extension on his seat
he does he likes to hold up none of the
seats go quite as tall as gym seat yeah
I don't even try that's yeah because
this is like a plastic fist on it it's
just relaxing to put my leg up like this
that's right I'm a short guy I'm a
little fella do you listen to your own
music no not from yeah well I mean you
do in the process enough reply sure yeah
once I mean you've listened to it so
many time yeah times from the you know
creation of the song to the demoing of
the song to the recording of this song
to the post you know mixing of the song
at my time and then you've got to go out
on the road you rehearse it so it's like
never for pleasure by the time it's
actually when it's on the radio you're
like alright I'm done with it will you
turn it off will you leave it on that's
a good question I won't turn it off how
about if you walk into a party and
they're playing or do you hate when
you're somewhere and they see that you
walk in and they put on I'm gonna tell
you it's the world
I see you over there it's like oh I
forgot the words thank you so much for
the reminder yeah I was in I was in the
Apple store the other day
it just kidding my wife's iPad fixed you
know baseball hat just you know sneakers
sure I'm just in there tank top and I'm
just laying low and all of a sudden
someone spotted me you know like tough
on the Jay Leno of heavy metal no I got
the jaw I was skiing completely covered
except for my lips and jaw and in some
guys like yo D what something like what
that helps hanging out
oh yeah the mouth face so and they say
they put on when I could take it in the
store you know oh my just in case you
didn't know he was here right now you
doing let's all just do this and point
that right and you know what it's
probably the one thing he's gonna want
to hear yeah is that song he's hurt no
he's gonna want he's gonna enjoy this
when did you see I what was that the bon
jovi was that a [ __ ] wedding and the
singer was making Bon Jovi sing one of
his own songs yeah it was humiliating is
my pet peeve and you know I think it
probably goes for comedians too for some
reason people won't expect entertainers
to do their job at a party or a
gathering and I'm gonna do mine on stage
you know and they want you Oh get up and
sing a song like what do you do well I'm
a mechanic we'll go rotate my tires
right yeah yeah yeah it's your day off
while I'm singing you go in the parking
lot you changed my tire exactly yeah
yeah I've disappointed so many people in
person
that's so great where they expect you to
be funny all the time is boring how are
you I wanna hang myself
all right good yeah look at [ __ ] wait
for you to do something yeah they expect
they expect you to be that person all
the time but with music I always hate
cuz comedian we don't plant they don't
play me on this like do radio musicians
you guys get in the car you'll just turn
on and hear yourself I'm like I don't
think it's gonna be awful
well they hear you're on the stations I
listen to the comedy channel oh I guess
so yeah yeah I don't listen to music
just the comedy channels I love that so
I hear you all time thank you you're
well covered thank you what genre do you
like besides metal
I like old R&B like what two older Sam
Cooke Otis Redding Wilson Pickett that
stuff Stax Motown yeah and you know
fifties you know doo-wop and that kind
of when was the last time something new
came out in any genre that you were like
this is good when I hear something new
that lights me up you know so like
there's a band I discovered called
monster truck their new band out of
Canada Toronto but they've kind of Grand
Funk meets Lynyrd Skynyrd but a bunch of
young guns and it's just it was like wow
that's awesome you know so got the
t-shirt and everything yeah but is when
you when you it's tough to get like as
once you're in the someone said to me
with some Tom Savini special effects
makeup oh yeah yeah said we get in the
business for the magic and then we
figure out how they do the trick you
know so the first thing we do we see a
band on stage go I want to be that guy
but then we find out it's not just magic
show up there it's recess you get into
it and I'm not griping I'm just saying
it no longer has it seemed the same
luster that it had when you're in the
audience with your jaw dropping just
looking at these guys from another
planet it's not another world anymore
now you see the reality of it yeah it's
you see what the real life is you got to
get on the bus right after you're tired
you can't slate like their normal job
babies I mean you know you make people
laugh and you do it well alright but you
what you learned is that set that was so
polished that you saw somebody blew you
away on stage you said I want to do that
that took like months to get that half
hour together you know and I'm learning
that from watching Seinfeld comedian in
cars which i think is really interesting
tonight get to just the study of it and
how it just and when his movie the
comedian sure he talked about just the
process of assembling all those pieces
to make five minutes to make 15:32 an
hour 90 minutes set get up there and do
an hour and a half for a comedian that
to go takes a long time to get that set
and then once you film it you got to
dump it once it's not old or got a dump
it that was the famous Johnny Carson
thing you get on Johnny Carson do you
show you kill and then you need new
material because there
he knows the job yeah they all get a
joke you're doing five minutes on Johnny
Carson you need everything plus five
minutes because you need new material
that is just as strong so that when
people go out and see your shows you're
still fine we're that five minutes has
to be like kind of a sprinkled in an
hour set so if you're doing a
five-minute TV set on Carson yeah
sprinkle in an hour set people will tall
well do you get that I mean dice had
that going where people wanted to hear
hickory dickory dock right they had to
hear like the hit yeah there's other
communities get that they want to hear
the hit there's been Phil yell but not
like kid those were iconic bits I toured
with stars for three years and they
would scream it he hated when they would
scream for the palms and if the crowd
was good he'd do him if he liked the
crowd he would do him but there's other
times we go no because they're annoying
him
they probably shout at you for the
monster rain story I yell monster rain a
lot yeah they'll yell that or they want
the character chip they'll yell yes I
just like Brian Regan I don't know if
you know Brian Regan he's a comic but
like he has to when I've seen him up
front at the top of this show say at the
end of the show I'm gonna do requests so
don't shout out anything let me do the
material and then I'll do your request
and that's how he keeps everybody and
then they all go clearly yeah I got
schooled by Eddie Murphy
I saw Murphy at the height even at the
Tillis Center I think a Long Island it
was if Saturday live whatever he's doing
his set and I yell out now I'm not
famous for that yellow dude buckwheat
[Laughter]
with Rick James [ __ ] she walked
offstage one night it's like when you're
doing 15,000 people and there's 500
yelling at it's like frustrating like
you once in a while you don't mind it
but when you're on that level and
there's that many people yelling those
things haven't stopped like his Rick
James thing the little John thing a
whole bunch of stuff from that TV show
yes iconic has lived on throughout and
you guys don't have the defense of a
Meijer I was rehearsing yesterday so my
voice is shot and I have to sing tonight
anyway right but you don't have the
defense of the loud wall of sound like
the rock band
always I've had so much respect I've
been friends with so many comedians Sam
and Bob Goldthwait and so many peas
yesterday yeah and you know and just the
idea of just you guys up through your
dick in your hand man and no word that's
it from the crowd can be ignored because
we just blasting rock'n'roll they can be
screaming we're not gonna take it the
whole show I don't hear it where I don't
have to respond to it you know so is
that what's going on because you have a
new solo album yeah for the love of
metal yeah do you like when you're
crafting what the live show is gonna be
to go along with this album do you go
okay we got to sprinkle in some hits
here and there to keep everybody at bay
it is absolutely the terror of every
rock star playing new material I've
heard Elton John just a couple years ago
song he goes yeah I'm going on a tour
I'm a little skating a little nervous
and they said what are you nervous about
he goes well I got a new album in a
minute you do a new song you see their
faces glaze over and I call it the
bathroom songs okay because you go the
minute it's like Pavlov's dog the minute
they hear the words here's one off the
new record you see people going yeah
piss you see I said I'd say it on stage
I can see you standing we slave we kill
ourselves we work on something we're
proud of and the minute we say here's a
new one you go to get a burger and a
beer you know so it does suck it sucks
but it's it's just so what I'm doing is
so much new material they don't got
enough piss in them I [ __ ] I got a
burger there's nothing else in this
building to do it doesn't matter who you
are I've heard a Paul McCartney talk
about it I saw Zeppelin on the Physical
Graffiti tour but they hadn't released
the album yet at Madison Square Garden
they went into Kashmir half the [ __ ]
place left to go to the bathroom Oh
cousin - Ezra garden you never heard
casually before
it just sound like a turd yeah and it
went on for two days so everybody so I
mean he was like you know you've seen
for the first time cashmere and nobody
knew what it wasn't it want to get a
beer and you at the Gramercy Villa
tonight you're at the Gramercy with with
Oh tip and Jamey Jasta who we love yeah
it's a listening party tonight for my
new album and Jamey Jasta and friends
I'm getting up there I'm getting up and
doing a few songs with joste and hotels
playing and it's gonna be fun this
record is completely unexpected I really
wasn't planning into anymore music and
just literally challenged me to do a
true metal record and I said alright
let's go and we went in no budget no
record deal just out of pocket and
started creating this thing and the
reviews of an incredible people here in
stuff in advance they're kind of stunned
that 63 year old Dee Snider has made the
heaviest record of his career and is
still like singing screaming like a lion
so do you get scared when it comes out
that people are gonna like it I mean cuz
music takes time like if I try a joke if
I write a joke that day I can try it
from an audience that night right so
this kind of an immediate and that's one
advantage to doing stand-up is you get a
much faster sense of what to do you have
the completed work and then they like it
or they hate it that's the live versus
and even a movie or a record or anything
like that no but I did a an album of
Broadway show too and so nothing scared
doing an album where you know the crux
of it would be how crazy you are you
could call it Deez Nuts
I would absolutely take advantage of it
the album is called for the love of
metal and it's available next Friday
July 27th which is when we're in
Montreal we are among them so everybody
should check it out yeah pre-orders
going on now at the martyr store calm
and video for becoming a storm is online
right now and a couple of songs are you
gonna do any more like a follow up to
the documentary that was on Netflix cuz
I watched it was great but it was the it
was basically the story of Twisted
Sister
before they got famous like yeah was a
[ __ ] sister well first of all that
was done
independently even though we supported
it because I saw some documentarian
heard or a story the fact that we were
together for 10 years before the world
discovered us and that's like stupid
amount of time yeah that's like really
you can't take a hint so um and so the
dock leak goes right up to the band
getting signed to Atlantic Records and
people say are you gonna do the second
half and I go well that's really behind
the music it's sorry but gotta be done
and that's the typical all the stories
are the same right they get the deal
they have a hit the band comes apart at
the seams
and then they reconnect right and the
reunion tour and they're fatter and
Balder and older and I go out there and
and you know and and and their friends
once more you know so that's kind of
predictable but we know the story so we
are twisted [ __ ] sister documentaries
is kind of surprising because most
people don't know that story what before
you have to write what's the longest you
guys went without talking 15 years it's
a long time